well that's also one thing I've always
admired about you in a lot of ways that
you just don't ever get caught up
in
the business whether it's social media
or just Hollywood you love how you love
Hollywood and different aspects you love
movies you love your family you love
your friends and the balancing is pretty
remarkable I don't know anybody who it's
almost absurd how removed you are from
Hollywood but yet you're still in
Hollywood because you don't live here
you have a full family life you don't
really go on social media that much
you're just yet you're working
um how do you do that are you just not
interested in that no it's it is weird
because I I love I always wanted to work
in Hollywood where I wanted to make
movies and I wanted to get in that make
movies or or animate if you know I I
majored in animation yeah I was always
really into art I wanted to do art I
just wanted to create I wanted to create
and make you know fun stuff and awesome
stuff and so I I love I love Hollywood
for sure but
I think after a while you know we were
just like it's hot here it's so hot I
love the Pacific Northwest having grown
up there and so that's why we moved back
um but you know I'll tell you man I and
I I know I've probably told you this
before but
I've always felt like
no matter where I'm discovering like I'm
constantly an outsider constantly an
outsider in the way like not when I grew
up you know where I grew up in in Oregon
like it was great perfect child I mean
it was a great child I loved it I'm
obsessed with it I always tell people
like how much if I could match that
childhood for my own kids or whatever
you know I love that but you know moving
getting you know going to college in
Utah and getting uh the Napoleon gig and
then moving out to LA yeah for sure I
felt like an outsider oh I'm this you
know small town guy I'm not the smallest
town not a total like hayseed but kind
of like hey
um I did not grow up in Hollywood I do
not have Hollywood parents or or any
kind of pedigree that or family tree
that you know worked in the business so
I'm here I feel like an outsider I've
always you know the entire time I lived
here but not in a bad way I kind of
embraced it and loved like oh that's
kind of what set me apart a little bit
um but then you know again like for the
reasons I just explained we moved
finally and um
and I love it up there but I now feel
like well I'm the Hollywood guy or at
least
it is in my blood to be like in
entertainment industry and up where I
moved up into Washington area it's like
there's not much of that no there's not
really much of that
and once again I feel like an outsider
but again in a good way like I love it
um you know people around me I mean boy
where we moved there's like countries
and farms and it's like some very
different vibe out there than out here
in LA and and I love them both I I yeah
it was hard to leave California I'm now
full on West Coast baby like just west
coast baby baby